what I'll be speaking about is the VA's
record system
I'll try to kind of cover this in three
parts one is what is the the my healthy
vet program that's the personal health
record system I'll give a quick overview
then talk about some efforts going on in
the VA to improve it through research
and evaluation and then give you an
example a few examples of ongoing
research projects related to this
personal health record system this quote
is a bit pessimistic but I think it
captures where we are this was two years
ago I think we're still about here but
many of the people in this room are
working on these issues so let me just
read this briefly in the current health
care delivery system most patients are
still not able to access their provider
when they need to don't know how to
manage their own health often do not
understand what the provider tells them
during a visit and do not have access to
their own health information when they
need it a chai tea has not been well
leveraged to address consumers needs and
allow them to best manage their health
and as a result of groups like this in
conferences we are changing this but
this is really this status quo right now
in health care very briefly the Veterans
Health Administration serves about a
quarter of US veterans about five
million ninety to ninety-five percent
male the numbers of females are rising
and the VA is becoming a bit more
user-friendly for women it's the largest
integrated health care system in the US
in general veterans who use vh a
services tend to be lower income lower
education in general less well at less
well-off than veterans who are using
other forms of care and a study by Lewis
caves cases a few years ago found that
veterans were used vh a compared to kind
of the general population getting care
and other health plans report themselves
as substantially worse off health-wise
so the my healthy vet program an
electronic personal health record system
it's what we call a tethered system that
is it's very closely linked to the VA's
own electronic medical record system if
you leave the VA and decide to get care
elsewhere it doesn't really go with you
it was launched in about 2005 the growth
has been more slow in terms of the
numbers of veterans using it compared to
a number of other high-profile systems
like group health and Kaiser absolute
numbers are pretty big because we've
started with a population of five
million veterans the goal is to help
veterans engage more in their care
provide them information and make care
delivery more efficient and maybe more
convenient so of the five million or so
veterans about a million little bit over
have done what's called registration and
that's a very easy online registration
system but it only gives you about ten
percent of the functionality you really
have to do something that they call IPA
or in person authentication you bring in
your ID you watch a ten minute video
sign a couple of forms one of the forms
is basically releasing information to
yourself ironically and then you can get
this higher level of service which
really is the full functionality was
refilling prescriptions has been the
biggest draw 19 million prescriptions
have been filled electronically since
2005 a new future that was described by
President Obama in one of his recent
talks is the blue button allows you to
download your medical information it's
somewhat limited because of the
functions available but it does allow
you to get a text file or a PDF a few
features I'll just run over very quickly
currently there's your medication list
you can refill your medications
allergies and immunizations look at what
appointments you have upcoming there is
secure messaging being able to send
email type messages to your health care
team
very soon if you look at the bottom
sorry about that you'll see that
chemistry and hematology are coming up
and something called delegation which
I'll talk about which is basically an
official way to share your record with a
family member a friend who you trust
there are also a number of features that
allow patients to input their own
information what an important thing
about this type of information is it
does not cross the barrier into the
electronic medical record it's really
just for the patient's own use their own
ability to organize their information
unless they decide to then print out
some of that information and bring it to
their doctor so they might enter their
supplements their over-the-counter
medications they might track their food
and wait there are also a number of
self-assessment tools for depression
PTSD I think I'll move over this fairly
quickly but what I wanted to show in
this side is the VA has been doing an
online survey of users of this personal
health record and they've been trying to
add features based on what the veterans
say they want so as you can see the
features that are in black are bolded
have now been added viewing upcoming
appointments was pretty new it was very
highly requested scheduling and changing
appointments actually I think this is
wrong I don't think you actually can
schedule yet but that's high on people's
priorities we took the medication refill
off of this because it's been been
addressed this is just a very brief view
of what it looks like for a veteran who
wants to do a refill they can see their
medication list here and if it's in blue
they are able to click on it and do a
refill or they can look over here and
this is found to be very easy to learn
and it's very popular
so what's interesting about my health
Yvette there are a lot of numbers of
veterans using it there are linkages to
quite a few VA databases not a not least
of which is the electronic medical
record pharmacy data they're doing
satisfaction surveys to understand
what's working and what isn't what
veterans like and would like to see more
of and importantly and that's where I'll
spend the rest of my time is that
there's a dedicated VA research unit
that is evaluating and trying to do
implementation science and improve the
personal health record and how it's used
in the VA this research unit is called
the eHealth quality enhancement research
initiative or the eHealth query it's
based at the bedford VA but is working
with at least eight other VA's around
the US including West Haven its goals
include to work with program offices
sorry about that and this is a very
important aspect in that it's not
supposed to be an ivory tower kind of
research but we work very closely with
the my health event program office and
our goals have to be closely aligned
with what their goals are and secondly
is there's a very large emphasis on
implementation science that is when
there are things that look good seem to
be working how do you get people to
actually use them in practice very
briefly the goals also include
increasing access and meaningful use and
enhancing veterans ability to self
manage their health conditions
a few illustrative projects that I will
skim over just showing you this list I'd
like to point out that we're trying to
look at really all levels so we're
thinking about whether clinicians and
and clinical staff are thinking about
this personal health record do they even
know that it exists we're working with
veterans who have various health
conditions including HIV and hepatitis C
we are looking at whether caregivers the
family members and friends can be
involved in that personal health record
and and using that information and we're
working with diverse groups and groups
that are often hard to reach homeless
groups as a example so very briefly the
clinic based project is looking at an
existing reminder that is in the
electronic medical record system that
indicates to a clinician whether a
patient who's in front of them has
registered for the personal health
record system it exists but it's rarely
used there it doesn't seem to be helping
in terms of getting more veterans to
sign up weird we've designed a project
to see whether some kind of wrap around
to that reminder could help maybe it's a
peer veteran who could talk to the
patient after their visit and say oh you
want me to show you how to sign up for
the system another would be making this
these videos and the signup process a
little more more efficient a project
that I'm leading is one that in which
we're taking groups of veterans one
group hiv-positive another group
hepatitis C positive these are people
who have had very little use of
computers in the past they were selected
because of their lack of use and trying
to understand whether a brief training
for in-person sessions at computers will
help them become more comfortable and
interested in using the system and here
was one person who after a couple of
sessions I thought this was quite
interesting she's now kind of learned
how to use the system and she says I
just get nervous going into it into my
health Yvette but that's
you know going okay is it going to let
me in and sometimes I make mistakes and
I have to reel aughhh in and then
there's times when it will tell me that
I logged in too many times and I won't
be able to do it for 24 hours I'm not a
sociologist or slightly psychologist but
there's a lot going on in here where
this anxiety about using the system this
was a 50 year old this anthropomorphic
view of the computer it's almost like a
real person and then this this fear of
making mistakes and if you make mistakes
you're going to be punished and by not
being able to use it so that these there
are a lot of users like this in the VA
we have a lot from the Vietnam era who
haven't may not use computers very much
another person though had this kind of
revelation that there's a lot out there
on the condition of interest and they
had no idea that Berkeley and Harvard
and Princeton and mayo clinic had
websites on their condition and that
this person just said this is really
cool just very briefly we are finding
that at least on self-efficacy and there
was increases over the this training
program and in just absolute number of
types of different internet uses this
there were increases a little bit less
so in our HIV group but these are very
small numbers sometimes people say that
internet and e health is a team sport
and and that's what this info more
informal caregiver project is about the
realization that for many people there's
somebody at home who's helping them with
their health condition and that person
may be better at computers and know how
to use them this here was an example of
a friend who was putting up his buddy a
veteran who had hepatitis C providing
room and shelter and some paid paid wage
but as a friend he could there was no
information he could get from the VA
about this person and he realized that
information was going to be very
important he said people that are
involved in day-to-day care of this
purse
need more information even if they have
to go in and sit down with the doctor or
the nurse because the treatment results
for the patient will be better in the
long term and yet he was quite
frustrated in trying to get information
I told the woman at the VA that I wanted
to know what the situation was or I was
going to throw the guy out of my house
because I didn't want to expose my
family to anything that could compromise
their health and I was told politely you
have no right for this information the
personal health record has a function
that they hope to roll out in the next
year or so called delegation which would
allow the patient to give permission to
this friend for example to look at his
record and co okay this persons in
treatment for Hepatitis C oh and they
have these three appointments coming up
oh and by the way they ran out of their
medication two months ago and maybe they
should get it refilled
so in this study we are planning to do
dyadic interviews find a veteran with
hepatitis C who has an informal
caregiver family member or friend and do
some in-depth qualitative interviews to
understand their relationship whether
that caregiver is helping them in some
instances we expect we'll find that the
caregiver could actually be preventing
them from getting on board with their
treatment if there's a issues with
alcohol and substance use the caregiver
may actually be a problem okay I guess
I've got one minute left them pretty
close here our goal is to then develop a
resource manual for these caregivers and
then ideally to develop some some
interventions around this delegation
function where we would make sure that
the caregiver is has access to the
veterans personal health record and then
this project is just in development we'd
like to work with homeless veterans and
cell phone use and use cell phones with
texts or phone calls reminding them
about appointments or some kind of
adherence depending on the condition we
choose basically to increase the
continuity of care for veterans and
there's a Providence VA has been doing a
lot of work in this area and we hope to
link up with them so just to wrap up
personal health records have an
advantage of timely 24-hour available
information we believe there's potential
for improving a lot of processes and
potential outcomes in the VA especially
there's a long way to go in getting
greater adoption we're basically at five
percent of veterans who use to help the
VA being signed up to use all the
functions and then there's an issue of
tailoring and making sure that the 50
year old is comfortable using the system
and finds it appropriate as well as the
25 year old who's coming back from Iraq
and just kind of the glib summary of
that is don't assume that everybody's 30
years old because they are